quant aux concurrents de la course
croisière saint malo pointe à pitre ils
passent leur dernière nuit au calme
avant le grand départ demain vers midi
eric tabarly donnera le coup d'envoi et
40 solitaire se battront alors pendant
près de trois semaines pour franchir en
tête la ligne d'arrivée saint malo la
cité des corsaires nous de façon
spectaculaire avec le grand océan devant
ses murailles la première
transatlantique française lâchera sur la
mer une cinquantaine de navigateurs
solitaires 6500 kilomètres de saint malo
à la guadeloupe avec un premier but
reprendre à l'anglais l'hégémonie qu'il
exerce sur l'organisation des courses au
large et surtout concurrencer la célèbre
transat ou tabarly s'illustra par deux
fois la différence actuellement avec le
nouveau règlement c'est qu'on peut
prendre n'importe quel bateau c'est
clair mais je craque sur tout le
parcours est différent c'est la première
fois qu'on part sur ce parcours ce sera
plus intéressant
il ya beaucoup plus d'options d'après
moi sur ce parcours la transat anglaise
a été marquée par l'empreinte tabarly
mais la transat française partira sans
lui enfin presque car c'est lui qui
donnera le départ il aura en plus la
satisfaction de revoir sur la ligne son
vieux pen duick iv le prestigieuse
ancêtre du trimaran de course
rebaptisé manureva par alain colas les
50 solitaire qui partiront pour une
traversée de l'atlantique n'ont pas tous
choisi les mêmes solutions il y aura au
départ une quinzaine de trimarans un
catamaran et toute une flotte y de
monocoques des trimarans il y en a de
toutes les femmes comme celui-ci as de
pique son skipper l'a construit lui-même
sa coque fait vingt mètres de long mais
environ 80 cm de large
d'autres ont choisi des bateaux de
croisière confortable comme jean pierre
barrau ancien skipper du bel espoir
le bateau du père jaouen
c'est pour prouver qu'un bateau de
croisière et qui fait complètement peut
naviguer naviguer vite même par rapport
à débattre très affûté sont destinés à
une course et qui peuvent pas faire
grand chose d'autre ça c'est l'intérêt
du constructeur mais l'intérêt du
skipper interne du skipper ben ma foi je
suis pas encore une vedette j'ai encore
jamais fait de course donc viser un
sponsoring pour un très grand bateau ou
pour quelque chose de très spécial c'est
difficile et je ne suis pas je suis plus
routier de la mer moi je fais des chais
les convoyages des choses comme ça je
fais pas tellement de courses alors
c'est plus pour le plaisir personnel sur
ton plaisir personnel puis pour aller
aux antilles et avec un bateau qu'il
faut l je resterai aux antilles avec le
bateau oui oui je vais bien quand même
je vais vite quand même le plaisir de la
course sans doute pour jean pierre
barrau pour d'autres c'est la
compétition et toutes ces contraintes
qui prime pas plus de trois quart
d'heures de sommeil consécutifs pendant
plus de vingt jours une alimentation
réduite au nécessaire
le bateau qu'il faut pousser à chaque
instant au maximum de ses possibilités
c'est cela la course une des formes de
l'aventuré humaine mail aventure tout
court existe-t-elle encore chaque
parcelle d'océan était sillonnée dans
tous les sens
cette route des antilles en particulier
laventure il faut peut-être alors la
chercher ailleurs
je pense qu'il reste peut-être pas à
tant au niveau de la compétition je
pense qu'au niveau compétition on est un
peu saturé
toutes sortes de nouveautés
c'est finalement il ya le côté aventure
disparaître petit à petit parce qu'on
devient de plus en plus sélectifs
maintenant les compétitions sont très
deviennent professionnels mais par
contre point de vue navigation et mer
mais reste des aventures extraordinaires
livre y'a qu'à voir damien en ce moment
au pôle sud
enfin il ya eu fini de rousseau
passagers nord-ouest yahia d aventure
formidable encore à faire en mer et il
s'en fait tout le temps il ya tout ce
dont on ne parle pas qu'ils font
toujours du monde ayant par tous les
jours cette transatlantique française
risque de réserver bien des surprises
à cette époque de l'année l'océan n'est
pas toujours tranquille
les prototypes construits spécialement
pour cette course risquent de souffrir
en cas de mauvais temps mais le trimaran
qui atteindront des vitesses
phénoménales dans les vents arrières des
alizés ont toutes les chances de
remporter la course
à moins que la grande porte bleue de
michel malinovski ne vienne remporté in
extremis le prix de 200 mille francs
offerts au vainqueur
demain en tout cas les concurrents de
cette course transatlantique auront pour
le départ droit un temps nuageux à
couvert avec un peu de pluie éparses